real quick a [ __ ] this is just like a
small little side thing but I found it
interesting Fox News host Jesse Waters
was confused by the existence of
Hispanic and Latin American Jews and he
genuinely is visibly confused it's it's
you know
it would be as if these people knew
something about anything it's in there
and he totally blows it because he was
in a hearing you remember Ted Cruz asked
him and you guys got weeks to prepare
for the hearing that's all they do is
prepare for hearings and he goes do you
have any people that cross the border no
Jiminy no kids that are in your cages
now do you even know if Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris went to the Border in 2021
no he couldn't answer he couldn't answer
anything now he was probably nominated
at least that's the what they touted
because he was Hispanic he was born in
Cuba his parents are Jewish which was
confusing to me but you know I don't
know a lot about about that stuff yeah
no we can tell you don't know much about
that and again it's just this is not
like that exotic or bizarre of a thing
um there are plenty of Jews in Central
and South America I'm Jewish I'm from
Argentina plenty of Jews in Argentina
Jews have lived in Cuba for a very long
time there are some Cubans who actually
their Jewish ancestry goes goes back to
this is a weird term but crypto Jews
Jews who were fleeing the Spanish
Inquisition and lived as non-jews but
were actually Jewish and
um there's been Jewish immigration to
Cuba
um you know between 1900 and 1950 and
many many countries in Latin America
with not insignificant Jewish
populations Argentina at the top of the
list with about 180 000 Jews as of eight
years ago these numbers have changed
Brazil has close to a hundred thousand
Jews Mexico 40 000 etc etc this is you
know it would be nice if I'm not saying
this is the standard by which we judge
whether people know anything
I don't know much about Jews in Latin
America but it would be nice if just the
reality of the world weren't so
confusing to Fox News hosts and to these
right Wingers who are so confident in
their opinions about everything but they
just know so little about everything as
well disappointing I think maybe is the
term I would apply let me know your
thoughts find me on Twitter at dpacman
quick break great Friday show for you
today
one of our sponsors is Helix sleep I
have been sleeping on a helix mattress
for years and I always recommend it to
friends you'd simply take this Helix
sleep quiz it asks you about your body
type your sleep position whether you
have back pain and then Helix will match
you up with the mattress that is
personalized to your needs and they ship
it to you for free another reason I went
with Helix is that unlike a lot of
mattress companies out there every
single Helix mattress is made in the USA
by a skilled production team which means
when you buy a helix mattress you're
supporting great jobs I'm not the only
one who loves Helix Helix was recently
awarded number one mattress by both GQ
and Wired Magazine every Helix mattress
comes with a 10 or 15 year warranty you
can try it a hundred nights and send it
back for a full refund if you need to
support the David Pacman show by getting
your next mattress from Helix sleep and
you'll get up to 350 off any mattress
plus two free pillows when you go to
Helix sleep.com slash Pacman the link is
down below